for our daily cancellation we're going
to cancel uh the new york times for a
lengthy article quite lengthy must be 8
000 words or more
just published um just published
yesterday here's the headline
convicted of sex crimes but with no
victims an online sting operation to
catch child predators snared hundreds of
men
but what were they really guilty of now
if you think that those of us who warn
of the normalization of pedophilia and
the sexualization of children are
suffering from paranoid delusions
you should really pay attention here the
article talks about a
sting operations conducted by law
enforcement to catch sex predators
and it focuses especially on um
operation net nanny which is the
initiative in washington state where sex
predators are lured
to a house to catch a predator style and
arrest it although it's not on tv this
is all just
a law enforcement operation but it's
quite clear that
the writer of this article michael
winterrip
wants us to feel sorry for these men who
get caught and he appears to see this
tactic of trapping potential sex
predators as unjust
and unfair and we should pity them for
it um
i will say that throughout the article
he does raise a few interesting points
one thing that he dwells on is the fact
that in many cases
men who actually molest and rape
children get lighter sentences than men
who get caught up
trying to molest kids in these sting
operations and i would agree that men
who actually molest kids
should get longer sentences in the same
way that a murder
a murderer should get a longer sentence
than an attempted murderer right
but the answer in my opinion is
extending the sentences for the child
rapists
not shortening the sentences for the
attempted child rapists
so an example that he gives is of a man
who who raped a 13 year old repeatedly
over the course of a year
admitted to molesting two of his
siblings
also but god then then was his sentence
was a minimum of seven years
meanwhile another man who got caught in
a sting operation trying to meet with an
11 year old for sex
got a minimum of 10 years now yes that's
absurd the rapist
ought to have gotten more than seven
years how about 70 years instead
um i don't think child rapists should
ever see the outside of a prison ever
again
but a guy who tries to meet an 11 year
old for sex even if there is no 11 year
old because it was an undercover cop the
whole time
is undoubtedly a threat to society and
should consider himself lucky to only
get 10 years in prison for that
so this is the way the article is kind
of set up
and it starts right off the bat giving
us an extremely sympathetic portrait of
a man
who wanted to rape a 13 year old girl um
here is uh here's the picture of the man
along with his mother so i think that
gives you a good idea pretty good idea
of how the new york times wants us to
view this
guy and let me read a little bit of this
to you
okay it says jace hembrich
worked as an apprentice laborer during
the weeks renovating homes around
vancouver washington and at neighborhood
gas stations on weekends
much of the rest of his life was online
he was hardcore amassing a collection of
more than 200 games people told him
it wasn't smart to be so so cut off from
reality but his internet life felt rich
as a dungeon master in dungeon dungeons
and dragons
he controlled other players destinies as
a video warrior he was known online by
his
by his uh nickname and was constantly
messaging fellow gamers particularly his
best friend simon
though the two had never met in person
over the last few years they paired up
as
teammates playing rainbow six siege and
rocket league
and grew close um this is this is all in
crucial information that we need about
this guy
at 20 hambrick was still living at home
with his mother big surprise
there to save money for college where he
hoped to study game design
he was a voracious reader who could
knock off a thousand page fantasy novel
in two days
blah blah blah blah blah etc giving us
his whole life story
and then finally one friday after work
in february 22
2017 hambrick came across a casual
encounters
w4m women searching for men post that
seemed meant for him
uh just gamer girl sitting home on
sunday it read
we can chat as long as i'm not
leveling i don't even know what that
means as long as i'm not leveling
hambrick emailed back
sounds like fun what game you playing uh
i am hooked on alien isolation gamergirl
replied
forget sex hambrick wrote let me come
watch
uh let me come watch i haven't gotten
that one yet adding that he was 20.
15 years 15 minutes later gamer girl
replied that she was 13.
hambrick was confused why did you post
an ad on craigslist if you're 13 you
mean 23
she asked for his cell phone number and
they switched to texting exchanging
photos
gamer girl was beautiful he thought if
he wasn't being pranked big eyes
cute white caps soft smile gazing up at
the camera serenely with a really nice
set of headphones
they exchanged a few texts about sex i
can be real bad if you're into bondage
he typed
but he was already hoping for more than
just sex i don't get out much he texted
i feel like if we get to talking i it
might go somewhere
you're beautiful and a gamer i might
have no problem hanging out with you
that's cool gamergirl replied and then
it gets into even more graphic stuff
with the guy talking about what he wants
to do to her sexually
do that is to a girl who told him he's
that she's 13.
now back to the article he it says was
this an elaborate game
again she claimed to be 13 the photos
seemed to tell a different story and the
gaming chair she was seated in
looked too expensive for a kid she well
parents could have bought it you know
she used slang a 13 year old probably
wouldn't know like ftp
it means f the police that originated in
80s hip hop
oh yeah i'm sure there's no 13 year olds
that know that the vulgarities and snide
tones seemed too adult her texts were
full of lols
was she an immature teenager or a sly
adult
her driving direction seemed too
specific for 13 hamburg texted that he
would be driving a red prius his
mother's
and gamer girl replied that she would be
wearing a gray sweatshirt and ripped
jeans it was a 20 minute drive to the
house
um after stopping for condoms he arrived
at 7 p.m three and a half hours after
their first email
she came to the door just as she'd said
in torn jeans and sweatshirt and um
and then uh it goes on and then he goes
inside and that's when
chris hansen shows up or you know
whoever's standing in for chris hansen
um you know the cops come out and uh
and and all of that and they live
happily ever after or the rest of us do
and he went to prison as he should and
the new york times wants us to feel
badly about that
because after all he was never actually
talking to a 13 year old and
he didn't he didn't think that she
looked 13
and uh she knew how to give driving
directions what 13 year old can do that
and she uses lol apparently 13 year olds
don't do that
of course none of this makes any sense
she told you she was 13. what you
thought this was a grown woman
pretending to be 13
and thus trying to attract child rapists
because she's into that sort of thing
now i'm sure there are freaks out there
in the slimy dregs of cyberspace who are
into that but that excuse just doesn't
cut it and shouldn't
a girl told you she was 13.
you came over to have sex with her end
of story
goodbye enjoy prison um
the article makes much of the fact that
these guys who get caught in these
stings
aren't really soliciting minors for sex
because they're actually talking to
undercover cops
it also tells us that a lot of the
predators don't have a criminal history
and many of them don't have child porn
on their computers
we're supposed to be impressed by that
apparently
and then it sort of skims over other
things that are that seem relevant like
the fact that half of the men caught in
this washington sting operation
were trying to meet children 11 years
old and younger
which makes them pedophiles by
definition
now yes there can be gray areas when it
comes to who ends up on the sex offender
registry uh you hear about cases
for example of say an 18 year old in a
relationship with someone a few years
younger than him
ending up on the registry even though
they're so close in age they could have
gone to high school together
now that is unjust i think most of us
can agree and wrong
that's not what we're talking about here
20 year old and a 13 year old
no gray area no mitigating circumstances
grown men looking to meet 11 year olds
no gray area
these are sex predators plain and simple
what about using these sting operations
to catch them well
um you know is there something unfair
about that
does it matter that they aren't actually
chatting with a real child
no and no first of all if you're told
that she's 13
you're perfectly free and able to say oh
never mind you shouldn't be on this site
kid
go tell your parents and walk away
there's no entrapment here because you
aren't being trapped at all you're not
backed into a corner you can walk away
second
catching predators and enforcing the law
against child molestation and rape and
sex crimes
that that's very difficult um these are
not easy laws to enforce
precisely the problem here is that so
often the laws are enforced
retroactively
and the after the crime has been
committed but then in that case the
damage has already been done to the
child
so now we're punishing a predator and
protecting the next victim but it's too
late to protect the first victim so law
enforcement tries to devise ways
to protect even the first victim to
smoke these guys out and get them behind
bars
before they're able to successfully hurt
a child
this isn't pre-crime like the minority
report you are catching people who are
actively trying to commit a crime it's
just that they're trying to commit it in
you might say a controlled environment
it's no different than a woman
who gets a murder charge for trying to
hire an undercover cop to kill her
husband
the point obviously is that if the
undercover cop hadn't been there
she would have hired a real hit man and
then we'd be arresting her after the
poor sap she's married to
is already six feet under so
what's going on here of all the problems
in the world of all the injustices to
expose
why are we getting a novel length
article telling us about the trials and
tribulations of men who tried to have
sex with pubescent or prepubescent
children
well it goes back to what we said at the
top there is in my
estimation a noticeable effort
underway in our culture to normalize
pedophilia and sexualize children
and to paint the men who prey upon
children as victims of an overzealous
and prudish system
this is just another example of that of
many and the examples are only
increasing
and that is why uh with great vengeance
we must
cancel the new york times again thank
you for tuning in to the daily wire one
of the fastest growing conservative
outlets in the entire country if you
enjoyed this video be sure to give it a
like and then subscribe to our youtube
channel so you don't miss out on any of
our content